GAVIN NEWSOM SPEAKS OUT ABOUT
THREE MASS SHOOTINGS IN THREE
DAYS IN HIS STATE.
>>> PROSECUTORS CALL HIM A
PREDATOR IN A WHITE COAT NOW A
DISGRACED FORMER GYNECOLOGIST IS
CONVICTED OF LURING FOUR WOMEN
TO HIS OFFICE TO ASSAULT THEM.
BUT THE ACCUSATIONS GO BEYOND
THOSE FOUR VICTIMS.
DOZENS OF OTHERS ACCUSED HIM OF
SEXUAL ABUSE.
INCLUDING MINORS AND PREGNANT
WOMEN.
BUT HE CUT A PLEA DEAL ON THOSE
YEARS AGO.
CNN REPORTED ON HIM IN 2020,
INCLUDING THIS FROM OUR LATE
INVESTIGATIVE CORRESPONDENT DREW
GRIFFIN.
>> Reporter: DR. ROBERT HADDEN,
SERVED NO JAIL TIME FOR HIS
CRIMES CUTTING A DEAL.
>> PATIENTS WEREN'T TOLD THE
OBGYN THEY WERE SEEING HAD BEEN
ACCUSED OF SEX CRIMES.
AND IN THE WEEKS THAT FOLLOWED,
TWO OF THOSE PATIENTS WOULD
BECOME HIS NEXT ALLEGED VICTIMS.
>> Reporter: EVELYN YANG WAS ONE
OF THEM.
>> YOU SAW EVELYN YANG THERE,
THE WIFE OF FORMER PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE ANDREW YANG.
SHE GAVE AN INTERVIEW TO DANA
BASH ABOUT WHAT SHE ENDURED AT
THE HANDS OF HADDEN.
BRACE YOURSELF IT IS VERY HARD
TO HEAR.
>> I WAS IN THE EXAM ROOM AND I
WAS DRESSED AND READY TO GO.
AND THEN AT THE LAST MINUTE HE
KIND OF MADE AN EXCUSE.
HE SAID SOMETHING ABOUT I THINK
YOU MIGHT NEED A C SECTION.
AND HE PROCEEDED TO GRAB ME OVER
TO HIM.
AND UNDRESS ME.
AND EXAMINE ME INTERNALLY
UNGLOVED.
AND AT FIRST I WAS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE, WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
AND THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM?
>> NO.
NO.
IN FACT, I THINK BACK TO MOST OF
OUR EXAMS, I DON'T THINK THERE
WAS ANYBODY IN THE ROOM.
>> YOU THOUGHT TO YOURSELF, THIS
ISN'T JUST INAPPROPRIATE BANTER,
THIS IS MUCH DIFFERENT?
>> OH, HE -- AT THAT MOMENT, I
KNEW THAT WAS -- I KNEW IT WAS
WRONG.
I KNEW.
I SAID, I KNEW I WAS BEING
ASSAULTED.
>> HE'LL BE SENTENCED IN APRIL.
HE WAS CONVICTED ON FOUR COUNTS
AND EACH CARRIES A MAXIMUM
SENTENCE OF 20 YEARS IN PRISON.
AND EVELYN YANG IS HERE NOW
ALONG WITH DANA BASH WHO WITH
DREW BROUGHT THIS TO LIGHT.
ALL THREE OF YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
EVELYN IS THE AUTHOR OF A KID'S
BOOK ABOUT SEXUAL ABUSE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
>> I KNOW YOU BARELY SLEPT.
IT'S ALMOST THREE YEARS TO THE
DAY THAT YOU SAT DOWN WITH DANA
AND THAT WE WERE ALL STUNNED
WATCHING YOUR STORY.
TO SEE THE CONVICTION, WHAT DOES
IT MEAN?
>> MY GOSH, I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS DAY FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME.
AND I THINK IT WAS SUCH A
VICTORY FOR EVERY WOMAN
INVOLVED.
EVERY HADDEN SURVIVOR I THINK
NOW CAN REST EASIER KNOWING THAT
FINALLY THIS MAN HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
>> YOU WERE SITTING IN THE
COURTROOM WHEN THE INVESTIGATOR
CAME DOWN AND YOU WERE SITTING
ALONGSIDE OTHER VICTIMS.
THE REPORTING FROM THE COURTROOM
IS THERE WERE QUIET SOBS.
>> SOME LOUD.
A LOT OF TEARS.
AND I THINK WE WERE ALL JUST
HOLDING IT IN.
HOLDING IT IN FOR THE DURATION
OF THE TRIAL.
CERTAINLY.
BUT EVEN FOR LONGER.
IT WAS JUST THIS WEIGHT THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN CARRYING FOR A
LONG TIME.
>> THIS WAS A LONG FIGHT FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU WORKED REALLY
CLOSELY WITH WHAT WAS CY VANCE'S
DA'S OFFICE IN NEW YORK.
YOU WERE TOLD WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THIS GUY DOWN AND THEN
THERE WAS THIS PLEA DEAL AND YOU
WEREN'T PART OF THE PLEA DEAL.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO TO SEE THIS.
>> WE HAD NO SAY IN WHAT KIND OF
PLEA DEAL HE WAS TAKING.
IN FACT, DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
UNTIL AFTER THE FACT.
UNTIL IT WAS ALL DONE.
AND IT WAS A DISAPPOINTMENT FOR
SURE.
AND I THINK THIS IS WHY WE WERE
ALL A LITTLE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT THE VERDICT
WOULD BE POSITIVE IN THIS CASE.
AND SO WE WERE ALL GRIPPING EACH
OTHER, LITERALLY, VERY TIGHTLY
AS THE JURY CAME BACK IN AND
WHEN WE HEARD THE WORDS GUILTY,
WE ALL LET OUT THIS COLLECTIVE
SIGH OF RELIEF.
AND A LOT OF TEARS, YEAH.
>> DANA, LET ME BRING NEW,
BECAUSE IT'S THE WORK YOU AND
OUR DEAR FRIEND DREW GRIFFIN,
WHO WE LOST A MONTH AGO, IT'S
THE WORK YOU DID TO BRING THIS
TO THE WORLD.
>> WELL, IT'S THE WORK THAT
EVELYN AND HER ATTORNEY AND ALL
OF THE WOMEN WHO CAME OUT
AFTERWARDS DID.
I CAN NOW SAY, EVELYN, I HOPE
I'M NOT BREACHING ANY
CONFIDENTIALITY.
BUT HOW THIS HAPPENED, I THINK
IT WAS CHRISTMAS EVE, 2019 I MET
YOU IN IOWA ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND YOU CALLED ME AND SAID
I TEXTED YOU A STORY.
I READ THE STORY ABOUT THIS PLEA
DEAL THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
AND YOU SAID, I AM ONE OF THOSE
ANONYMOUS WOMEN.
I WAS ASSAULTED BY THIS MAN WHEN
I WAS PREGNANT.
AND WE TALKED FOR A WHILE AND
YOU SAID YOU WANTED TO COME
FORWARD.
BUT IT WAS UNDERSTANDABLY VERY
HARD.
AND I WAS TAKING THE TRAIN TO
NEW YORK TO DO THE INTERVIEW AND
IT WAS TOUCH AND GO, AGAIN
UNDERSTANDABLY BECAUSE IT WAS SO
EMOTIONAL.
AND IT WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS THAT I HAVE WITNESSED
SOMEBODY DO, WHICH IS TO GO
THERE AND BRING BACK ALL OF THE
TRAUMA, REALLY TRAUMA THAT YOU
EXPERIENCED.
AND YOU DID IT.
AND YOU DID IT BECAUSE YOU KNEW
THAT THIS WAS IMPORTANT.
NOT JUST FOR YOU BUT FOR SO MANY
OTHER WOMEN.
AND THEN, I MEAN, YOU -- CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG, BUT SINCE THEN
THAT WAS ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO,
WITH DREW GRIFFINS AMAZING
REPORTING OUR TEAM NELLIE BLACK
AND PATRICIA DE-CARLO WE SAW
WOMAN AFTER WOMAN COME OUT HOW
MANY THAT WE KNOW OF?
>> UPWARDS OF 350.
350 WOMEN.
>> HUNDREDS OF SURVIVORS.
>> AND WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
MORE.
A LOT OF WOMEN ACTUALLY STILL
DON'T KNOW, HIS FORMER PATIENTS
TO THIS DAY DON'T KNOW THAT HE'S
NOW TWICE-CONVICTED SEX FELON.
AND THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE
DONE ON THAT FRONT.
COLUMBIA AND THE HOSPITAL STILL
HAS SOME WORK TO DO IN TERMS OF
NOTIFYING PREVIOUS PATIENTS.
AND, YOU KNOW, EVERY TIME I DO
AN INTERVIEW, MORE WOMEN COME
FORWARD AND ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THEY ASK IS HOW DID I
NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS?
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN A KNOWN
PREDATOR FOR MANY YEARS.
I REALLY CREDIT, I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU, DANA, AND TO YOUR
TEAM, FOR CREATING THE SPACE FOR
ME TO COME FORWARD.
AS YOU MENTIONED, IT WAS AN
AGONIZING DECISION.
AND I THINK YOU PROBABLY RECALL
ME CANCELLING AND RESCHEDULING.
>> I MAY REMEMBER THAT.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> BUT I HAVE NO REGRETS.
THE REASON WHY I AGONIZED OVER
THE DECISION IS, YOU KNOW, YOU
JUST CAN'T PREDICT HOW THE
PUBLIC OPINION WILL TREAT YOU,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN AND MINORITY
WOMEN, IN CASES OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY REGRETS
BECAUSE SOON I CAME FORWARD,
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN FELT AT EASE
TO COME FORWARD AS WELL.
AND THAT, IN ITSELF, WAS A BIG
DEAL.
BUT THE JOURNEY THAT LED TO THIS
DAY AND THIS VERDICT, I THINK,
WAS A COLLECTIVE EFFORT.
YOU KNOW, SO MANY OF THE WOMEN
WHO CAME FORWARD AFTER ME BECAME
INCREDIBLE SELF-ADVOCATES AND
ADVOCATES FOR OTHERS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO PASS THE ADULT SURVIVORS
ACT IN MAY, WHICH ACTUALLY OPENS
UP THE WINDOW FOR ALL SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK TO FILE A CASE IN
COURT NO MATTER WHEN THE ASSAULT
HAPPENED.
SO THIS WILL AFFECT NOT JUST HAD
DEN SURVIVORS BUT SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS EVERYWHERE.
>> CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING
BRIEFLY.
THIS IS A TESTAMENT TO THE
NOTION OF SHARING STORIES EVEN
WHEN THEY'RE HARD AND WHAT AN
IMPACT THEY CAN HAVE.
THAT CERTAINLY HAPPENED WITH
EVELYN.
IT'S ALSO A TESTIMONY TO SHOE
LEATHER REPORTING.
I HOPE OUR LATE COLLEAGUE, DREW
GRIFFIN IS SMILING FROM HEAVEN
THAT ONE OF THE MANY, MANY
STORIES THAT HE WORKED ON HAS
HAD SUCH AN IMPACT TO BRING WHAT
WE DO -- WHAT WE WANT TO DO AT
THE END OF THE DAY IN OUR JOBS,
WHICH IS SHINE A LIGHT ON THINGS
AND IN THIS CASE JUSTICE.
AND HIS REPORTING BROUGHT
JUSTICE TO EVELYN AND HUNDREDS
OF OTHER WOMEN.
>> IT REALLY DID.
IT IS, AS YOU KNOW, SO WELL
DANA, THE CORE OF WHO DREW WAS
TO THIS WORLD AND TO ALL OF US.
AND WE ARE EVERY DAY GRATEFUL
FOR WHAT HE DID.
DANA, YOUR REPORTING TOO.
YOU TOLD IT IN A WAY ONLY YOU
COULD.
SO THANK YOU, DANA.
>> THANK YOU, EVELYN.